شركه عشرات من الفلسطين ظهر اليوم في
تظاهره شعبيه تحت شعار مسيره الخلود
للمطالبه بتحرير جثامين الشهداء المحتجزه
لدى سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وقد انطلقت
التظاهره التي دعت اليها الفعاليات
الوطنيه والاسلاميه في محافظه رام الله
والبيره من امام مدخل مخيم الامعري
للاجئين وسط مدينه رام الله وتوجهات الى
حاجز قناه العسكري شمال القدس المحتله
من حاجز قلنديا شمال القدس ينضم الى مراسل
الجزيره سمير ابو شماله اذا تم قمع مسيره
الخلود واضح ان المشهد يترعى عليه التوتر
كما يبدو من ابتدائك الخوذه
عبد الصمد
بشكل
متظاهرين قد حاولوا الوصول الى حاجز
العسكريه الجنود الاحتلال الاسرائيليين
خرجوا من الحجز العسكري من الدوريات
العسكريه وقاموا فورا بقمع المسيره او
تظاهره بقنابل الصوت وقنابل الغاز المسيء
للدموع وايضا الرصاص
كما تسمعون هناك حتى هذه اللقطه ما زال
جنود الاحتلال يحاولون قمع هذه او يقنعون
هذه المسيره بقنابل الصوت وايضا ربما
تشاهدون على الكاميرا مباشره هناك احد
الجنود يحاول تصويب البندقيه نحو
المتظاهرين ولكن هذه تظاهره التي انطلقت
من مخيم الامعري للاجئين وسط مدينه رام
الله وقد انتقلت الى مدخل مخيم همم قلنديا
اللاجئين ايضا القريب من حاجز قلنديا
العسكري وانضم اليه العشرات اخرين من
الفلسطينيين الاعلام الفلسطينيه
والده الاسير ناصر ابو حميد
وللتمديد باستمرار جريمه الاحتلال باحتجاز
جثامين الشهداء الفلسطينيين في ثلاجات
الموت وما يعرف فيما يعرف بمقابر الارقام
حتى هذه اللحظه هناك محاوله من
الفلسطينيين التعبير عن غضبهم واحتجاجهم
اذا هذه السياسه برشا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه بالحجاره وايضا جيش الاحتلال
يرد عليه باسلحه همم
المتوفره بين يديه لقمه هذه التظاهره لم
يسمح جيش الاحتلال بوصول هؤلاء المتظاهرين
الى هذا المكان او الى حاجز قلنديا
العسكريه فورا تم قمعها بشكل مباشر وايضا
كان هناك مبين المتظاهرين الكبار السن
وايضا شيوخ واطفال قد شاركوا في هذه
المسيره التي كما ذكرنا انطلقت من همم
امام مدخل مخيم الامعري والمدخل والمخيم
الذي كان يعيش فيه الاسير الشهيد ناصر ابو
حميد احد القيادات الفارسه في حركه فتح
ولد استشهد همم قبل اسبوع في سجون
الاحتلال لجراء سياسه الاهمال الطبي التي
تمارسون الاحتلال تجاه الاسرى الفلسطينيين
ونحن نتحدث بالارقام عن اكثر من 600 اسير
فلسطيني يقبعون في سجون الاحتلال هم من
المرضى عشرات منهم من اصحاب الامراض
المزمنه والمصابين باورام سرطانيه ولك
القوات الاحتلال تمارس عليهم سياسه
الاهمال والثاني هناك
اكثر33 شهيدا قد استشهدوا وسقطوا همم
السجون الاسرائيليه جراء هذه السياسه على
الاسرائيليه قد سقطوا الشهداء في داخل ال-
ال- السجون الاسرائيليه وهم من الحركه
الاسير اقيمه تشاهدون هناك تجمع لجنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه عند الدوريات
العسكريه القريبه من حاجز قناه العسكري
بالضمه هذا مخطط تكتيكي على الانقضاض على
المتظاهرين مره اخرى الذين يحاولون التقدم
اكثر على الحاجز العسكري من خلال رشق
الجنود الاحتلال بالحجاره ويتقدمون اكثر
نحو الحاجز وبالتالي ربما جيش الاحتلال
يحاول التمهيد لقمع هؤلاء المتظاهرين مره
اخرى بقنابل الغاز او اطلاق الرصاص
المعدني المقلد المطاط والقنابل الصوت
بمناسبه الجيش الاسرائيلي حول قناع قطعنا
ايضا قنابل الصوت عندما همم همم رشقنا
بقنابل الصوت ويحاول همم اجلاءنا من هذا
المكان اا كما تشاهدون ههه قبل الصوت قبل
الصوت
قنبله الصوت بيننا بين صحفيين
بين الصحفيين
هناك
وسائل الوقايه
ومعروفون لدى الجيش الاحتلال يقومون بهذه
التغطيه ولكن جيش الاحتلال لا يعجبه هذه
السياسه هذا الاسلوب من قبل الصحفيين
الذين يغطون هذه السياسه اتجاه القمع
الفلسطينيين في هذا المكان وبالتالي هناك
عمليات قمع ايضا للصحفيين من خلال القاء
القنابل الصوتيه تجاه
الفلسطينيين الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه
اللحظات ايضا يتجمع عند هذا المكان وهناك
المتظاهرون ما زالوا يتواجدون عند حديث
تلك النقطه التي تشاهدون على الشاشه
مباشره ويقومون برج الحجاره من عده زوايا
تجاه جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيليه جيش
الاحتلال بكل تاكيد هو يحاول همم
صحفيين وايضا يحاول طردنا من هذا المكان
في كل لحظه يقومون
بعرقله عملنا كحفيين في هذا المكان كما
تلاحظون يحاولون
المرور الى الجانب الاخر وذلك ربما
يحاولون اقفال هذه سياره او ربما
مصادراتها لا نعرف ما هو الامر لكن الجيش
الاحتلال
اخذ المفتاح هذه المركبه
الفلسطينيه واخذ المفتاح وترك الشاب
داخلها ولكن اا
يحاول منع السيارات والمركبات من اجتياز
هذا الشارع الرئيسي وهو شارع الحيوي الذي
يمر من عند قرب حاجز قلنديا باتجاه رام
الله وايضا القادمين الى مدينه القدس
المحتله الجيش يبدو في هذه هذه هذه التوتر
هذه السياسه يحاول استفزاز الفلسطينيين
والمواطنين انه انت حتى الصحفيين في هذا
في هذا المكان هذه المسيره التي انطلقت
بعنوان مسيره الخلود هي كانت سلميه كانت
مسيره سلميه شارك فيها عشرات من
الفلسطينيين همم انطلاقا من مخيم الامعري
للاجئين وسط مدينه رام الله وكانت هدفها
الاساسي كان هدفا واضحا هو للاحتجاج امام
هذا الحجز العسكري والمطالبه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي بدات بتنفيذ هذه السياسه
منذ عام 2015 باحتجاز 117 جثمان شهيد
وشهيده وكان اصغرهم بالفتى شادي همم اسبوع
وهو من مدينه جنين يكون عمر خمسه عشر عاما
جيش الاحتلال ما زال يمارس هذه السياسه
وايضا الفلسطينيون يحتجون على هذه السياسه
التي هي همم
يعتبرونها سياسه لا اخلاقيه ولا انساني
انساليه اتجاه الفلسطينيين الذين يحتج
فيتامين ابنائهم وفلداته اكوادهم في
ثلاجات الموت او فيما يعرف به المقابر
وارقام هناك حلب كما ذكرنا همم عبد الصمد
هناك جيش الاحتلال ما زال يقبع هناك
الفلسطيني يحتاجون بهذه الوسائل المتاحه
بين ايديهم دمشق بالحجاره فقط
انفاسك المذكر فقط بان ليله الماضيه شهيره
حمله اعتقالات همم واسعه في الغربيه قامت
بها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وشمله اكثر
من 20 سنه فلسطينيه في عدد من المناطق
الضفه الغربيه وكان اللافت هو ان همم تركز
همم حمله الاعتقالات على بلده سروال رام
الله لماذا سلواد سمير
يعني هناك محاولات من قبل الجيش الاحتلال
بما يعرف بحمله كاس الامواج التي انطلقت
منذ شهر اذار مارس من العام الثاني والتي
تستهدف من خلالها قوات الاحتلال بملاحقه
المطلوبين لديها في جميع المناطق
الفلسطينيه بالامس كان هناك حمله اعتقالات
تركزت في مدينه جنين باغلبيه اللحن همم
اعداد المعتقلين اليوم في سلواد كان هناك
اقتحام لهذه البلده وهي التي تقع شرقيه
مدينه رام الله وهاد قد تم اعتقال 13
فلسطينيه بعدم منازلهم وايضا كان هناك
مداهمه بشكل وحشين كما وصفتها تقارير
المؤسسات الحقوقيه لمنزل همم الرئيس نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني قدوره فارس وذلك من
ذريعه ان جيش الاحتلال كان يطالب باعتقال
نجله همم ورد ولكن قوات الاحتلال ايضا
اقتحمت نادي سلواد الرياضي ايضا وحطمه
ابوابه في هذا المكان خرابا وفساده
وتخريضا
هذا ال- ال- هذه المؤسسه الرياضيه كما ان
هناك ايضا همم استهداف لمنازل المواطنين
في همم مدينه نابلس التي اعتقل منها سته
فلسطينيين من بينهم احد اسرع الذين امضوا
في سجون الاحتلال 20 عاما عبد الرحيم
بشكاره الذي اعتقل من مخيم عسكر والذي
اطلق سراحه في شهر مارس اذار الماضي اذا
هناك سلسله من
الاعتقالات وايضا المحاولات القتل
والمداهمه والقمه كمان وراء احد في هذا
المكان وحتى في مدينه القدس المحتله الذي
جرى هذا اليوم من خلال مجموعات المستوطنين
الذين يحاولون على الارض تابعه مستاجره من
قبل الفلسطينيين من قبل همم كنيسه
اشكرك سمير ابو مراسله الجزيره